[Music]
on the Gary Vaynerchuk Channel yeah
YouTube really a lot of fun right now
daily be we're I'm so obsessed with only
posting daily be on the Gary Vee YouTube
channel that I'm creating a secondary
channel slash Gary Vaynerchuk for my
business meetings my keynotes things of
that nature
I'm not convinced that this is the right
strategy I'm really not what I am
convinced about is I want to go Monday
actually assume now meeting with in
meeting
I want to go Monday through Friday with
daily be and then Saturday and Sunday do
the stuff that actually drives to Gary
Vaynerchuk maybe we can call it gallery
Vaynerchuk weekend and drive towards us
cuz it's that content what are you
driving so we'll talk about this I'm
sorry let me just finish up this but
like but I don't want to crowd the
channel with two posts per day like we
were doing so wonderful Saturday and
Sunday we do Gary Vaynerchuk YouTube
channel stuff and siphon the daily be
million you know 850,000 to Gary
Vaynerchuk which is right now 51,000
right right now we deserve so much that
we can post every day honest well I want
to and but I want so for the weekends
forward is prioritizing keynotes on on
Gary Vee Gary Vee right now is only
Monday through Friday Monday through
Friday got it fine I should probably do
a little so then we got to start either
we use this clip or we need to create an
original PS there's a Gary Vaynerchuk
Channel kind of thing I got actually got
idea hey guys thank you so much for
watching they want to do a follow up to
it where you do a call to action to your
audience if L the survey okay I've
looked at it and the questions were like
kinda man but I figured if we and they
don't they're not talking about how
we're gonna distribute the results yes
right now they're just game you're gonna
do a video and they would share that
video of like hey so of this survey
browse they go if we come up with a good
survey that we
it's gonna have strong results that you
can then make make a post-mortem thing
often that they'll post on their
channels I wasn't listening what up
brother how are you very good man what's
up quick my friend Juan who I'm really
impressed with watching him grow as a
young entrepreneur and hustler hit me up
he's doing a GoFundMe for obviously the
very difficult times in Mexico City that
are brewing post all the earthquakes and
I'm just really excited to support him
about the post on Instagram right now
obviously bringing awareness to causes
and things that make sure is most of you
know most of the stuff that I do is
always behind the scenes there's a lot
of noise around events and so I've
always trying to be strategic around
delivering stake when it matters more so
than sizzle like a tweet here a thing
there like everybody feels good about
themselves as an advocate I tend to like
to just do it quietly that's my norm but
but you know sometimes you just go
random and you do stuff in a different
way and so I'm really excited about
posting this this video on Instagram
right now and putting it in the blog and
and bring the awareness to his GoFundMe
that has already generate a quarter
million dollars to help out individuals
in Mexico City build their homes back up
and so that's what I'm up to right now
before the wine event that's amazing
brother I'm literally about to fill my
piece of content right now
okay I'm literally taking screenshots of
this face time I may use this content as
the main thing because um because it
might be the most kind of authentic
version of it you know the best part is
I already took what I needed while you
don't know it was coming so that it was
real
good all right so so listen man I'm
super impressed by you in general and
then for you to be giving back to your
country this way inspires the [ __ ] out
of me so I'm exactly pumpka to support
and so I'm on it right now and and I'll
talk to you soon a hundred percent
I'll talk to you soon my man by relevant
experience que pasa el pais euros to ye
ye Summa contra impotency I in sentiment
oh really yes prosecutor compartir
assessed historia con el mundo his class
guy is in Mexico say anuradhapura
service cap Posada kill terremoto
televised edificios en polos esta Levant
and o.k restaurant assistance in window
comida gratis para todo el pueblo que o
tell assess and receive en de gente see
in cost o qué tanto de niro's como
doctores como ellos están trabajando
gratis Kate on dolare de teléfono como
de internet esta abierta para que la
gente SE puede communica repo a
contractor AHS seres queridos
y que los hospitals estan Muertos
abierta Theresa viendo a cada persona
que lo necesita
los doctores estan trabajando table - no
se que Mucha gente el mundo que quiere
donar yo no sé como yes purse okay oi
vamos a hacer and go for me link clover
me me
[Music]
so something that has been really
beneficial to me is Steven Ross not
because I actually use him as Steven
Ross with my business partner he owns
the Miami Dolphins he owns a piece of
Boehner X Business School Michigan he's
76 years old 77 years old and he acts
like me and he actually kids younger
than me he's 77 and on straight [ __ ]
fire and it's been great because I when
I got to him I'd come out of a decade of
Silicon Valley 19 year olds right and
like I'm in such a great place in I'm 41
years old I'll be 42 in November and I
think for real and a lot of probably why
I think I could buy the Jets and other
things as and I I talk afar a lot about
this we're very friendly and I'm always
like we're just starting this is like
where do you think we are like I you
know I think I genuinely think a 55 year
old executive a 55 year old executive is
fairly like I don't know getting close
to maybe halftime hey guys thank you so
much for watching dailyvee I really
appreciate it as you can tell we've
taken a new YouTube channel strategy and
we've created a second channel slash
Gary Vaynerchuk please subscribe that is
where business meetings and keynotes are
gonna reside not sure this is the right
strategy of having two channels but [ __ ]
it I'm gonna try some [ __ ] go subscribe
check it
[Music]
you've been in it Phil's been in every
[ __ ] room in New York so the [ __ ]